الدوله الاقوى اقتصاديا في العالم هي
الولايات المتحده لكنها تتصدر ايضا قائمه
الدول صاحبه الدين الاكبر عالميا وهو رقم
اعتبر ضخما جدا الدين الامريكي مشاهدينا
يبلغ الان نحو
31.4 تريليون دولار وهذا الرقم يحصل لاول
مره في التاريخ الامريكي والاسباب كثيره
منها الوباء والحروب وفقا لخبراء الاقتصاد
ليس هذا فحسب بل هناك شكوك حول عجز
الولايات المتحده عن سداد هذا الدين قبل
الاول من يونيو من عام 2023 وهو الموعد
المقبل مع استمرار عدم توصل الكونجرس
لاتفاق حول رفع سقف الدين وبالتالي هذا
امر قد يعود بالكوارث على الاقتصاد وعلى
الولايات المتحده والاقتصاد العالمي برمته
لكن السؤال هنا ما هو سقف سقف الدين
مشاهدينا هو المبلغ الاجمالي للاموال التي
يحق للاداره الامريكيه والحكومه الامريكيه
تحديدا اقتراضا للوفاء بالتزاماتها
الماليه والحاليه مثل مدفوعات الضمان
الاجتماعي استرداد الضرائب وغيرها وعندما
يحدث فرق بين الدين الحكومي والانفاق
السنوي هنا يحدث ما يعرف اقتصاديا بالعجز
في الميزانيه وهنا ياتي السؤال الاهم ايضا
ماذا لو تخلفت الولايات المتحده عن سداد
الدين الذي يبلغ كما ذكرنا قبل قليل اكثر
من 31 تريليون دولار امريكي هنا يرى
الخبراء بان اخطر العواقب هو انهيار قيمه
الدولار المهيمن على حركه التجاره
العالميه فبالنسبه للشركات الامريكيه ان
هيمنه الدولار تعني انها لا تخضع لمخاطر
سعر الصرف مثل منافسيها الاجانب
عالميا فقد تجبر بعض الحكومات والشركات
على دفع فواتيرها بالدوليه طبعا بعملات
اخرى ما قد يشكل خطرا على استقرار الاسواق
الماليه العالميه اما هنا جو بايدن الرئيس
الامريكي فقد المح للوجوه الى التعديل
الرابع عشر من الدستور لرفع دين الحكومه
سقف دين الحكومه الامريكيه لكنه اشار الى
ان الوقت لن يسعفه للقيام بذلك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات